- Oh my God.
No you didn't, Doctor Mike.
- I donated over $100,000
to Ryan Trahan for Feeding America,
and I get to choose his tattoo.
Well, you're gonna get
to choose his tattoo.
And we're actually gonna talk to Ryan,
see what he's up to,
see how the Penny
Challenge is coming along.
Let's watch some Ryan Trahan content.
Peewoop!
- 50 hours starts now.
- 50 hours in darkness!
That's serious.
- [Ryan] It is completely
dark in this house.
Blackout curtains,
all the lights have been covered up.
- The way your body adapts
to darkness is by allowing your iris
to relax the muscle
surrounding your pupil,
opens it up right there.
Your pupil's wide, allows
maximum light to come in.
Remember, it's the rods in
your eyes that are responsible
for night vision, darkness vision.
But if you wanna have perfect adaptation
to darkness, it takes a few hours.
(body thuds)
(Ryan shouts)
That's gonna be an injury.
He needs a doctor.
I'm here for you, Ryan
- As you guys know, it's
take no days off around here.
- Working out in the dark
is not medically recommended.
That could potentially
cause a lot of injuries.
See, I wouldn't do this with weights.
I would just do the bodyweight exercises.
Pushups, crunches, squats,
lunges that sort of thing.
- Nighttime routine.
Haley actually got me a
bunch of new skincare,
so I look forward to my nighttime routine.
- How did he know that was his toothpaste?
(dramatic music)
Something about that is fishy.
If you have a nighttime bag
with a bunch of creams and stuff,
how'd you know that was toothpaste?
Hmm?
(Ryan spits)
(Doctor Mike laughs)
- That's facial cleanser.
(dramatic music)
- How did he know that
that was facial cleanser?
"The security camera caught me at 3:00 AM.
I don't remember."
Oh, sleepwalking.
That's funny.
This is actually fairly common.
Not eating five bags
of fruit snacks.
Sleepwalking happens
during the non-REM phase
of your sleep, usually
happens an hour or two in.
It's one of the deepest,
it's the deepest stage
of your sleep.
People don't remember it.
Usually someone else has to
alert them that it's happening.
And studies show one in two people
get injured sleepwalking,
could be a minor injury,
but they still do get injured.
You wanna make sure that
if that's happening,
you figure out the
underlying reason as to why.
Stress is one of the leading factors.
- [Ryan] Right about now is
when time just completely
stopped being a thing for me.
- So not having exposure
to light can actually
break your circadian rhythm,
your natural circadian rhythm
of when you wake up, when you go to sleep
because there are sensors in your brain,
in your eye that get
triggered by light entering.
So that's why I always say that one
of the first things you should do
in the morning upon waking
is opening shades, getting bright light.
And I know not every area in
the world has access to that.
So you could fake it with
some artificial light.
"Testing if I'm still lactose intolerant."
Ah, this is gonna be a brutal test.
You know, it's funny.
A lot of patients will
come see me in the hospital
and be like, "Am I lactose intolerant?"
I'm like, "If you drink a quart of milk,
do you have massive diarrhea?
That's your answer."
- [Ryan] Plowed a slice of cheese,
and then I ate yogurt, and
butter, and cream cheese.
And I remembered, I didn't even-
- Why is he doing this?
- Finally, demolished a cup of milk.
Now we wait.
I was waiting for about 30 minutes
when the unimaginable happened.
(stomach gurgling)
I sprinted to the bathroom,
and my chihuahua was
sitting on the toilet.
- That's a chihuahua?
That's a hairy chihuahua.
- And I'm still lactose intolerant.
- Yeah. That's a lot of diarrhea.
Can only imagine the sounds
that came out of that bathroom.
(bomb explodes)
(tone beeps)
- [Sam] Can you overcome
a lactose intolerance?
- Some individuals can eat
certain dairy products,
some can drink milk
Lactaid,
and some can take supplements
like a lactase supplement.
- I just put on this sauna suit.
I am drenched.
- Well, people use sauna
suits for cutting weight,
specifically wrestling, boxing,
MMA, that sort of thing.
Not a huge fan of it.
In fact, I wish those sports would change
the way the weigh ins are done
to be done on the same day,
so people don't cut weight.
- I'm gonna be wearing
this for 24 hours straight.
I live in Texas.
That sun right there?
- Oh, that's dangerous.
You could easily, not only dehydrate,
but develop heatstroke.
Which heatstroke is deadly,
like legitimately deadly.
- [Haley] Is it a 24 hour challenge?
- Yeah.
- Have you consulted a doctor?
- Haley, I called the doctor.
- I'm right here, bro.
Just call me.
(upbeat music)
- Doctor Mike.
- What up!
The doctor's on call.
- I need to ask you what you
think of this, all right?
- I'm feeling the outfit.
It looks fire.
Is that the new Versace line?
(record scratches)
The worst joke ever.
How did I think that was funny?
That's clearly Gucci.
Medically, it's not safe.
- Oh dear.
- 'Cause unlike going into
a sauna where you sweat
and your sweat can actually
evaporate, thereby cool you off,
- Yeah.
- that sauna suit will prevent
the cooling off process.
That guy knows what he's talking about.
So you will sweat, you will be dehydrated,
you will lose some electrolytes,
and you will overheat.
- Better go get some water, huh?
- And not just water,
electrolytes.
- I lift up my arm,
and a massive pool of sweat trickles
down my armpits
and into my nether region.
- Fungus.
(tone beeps)
(mysterious synth music)
I've went in a sensory deprivation tank
and did a whole video on this.
It's silent, it's dark,
and you're floating.
Kinda feels like an alien movie.
- [Ryan] I'm gonna be doing
the maximum legal time
in this thing, three hours.
One with no gravity, one
with no gravity or light,
and one with no gravity, light or sound.
Complete sensory deprivation,
which apparently can
have some side effects.
- Yeah.
Those things can happen,
but there's a lot of good
effects as well that can happen.
I will say, going to these
sensory deprivation things,
my biggest issue with them
is that they make way too many promises
as if they're certified.
"One hour in a sensory
deprivation tank is equivalent
to X number of years of
meditating", which is nonsense.
Making promises about
rejuvenating one's immune system
or sleep cycle.
Taking a break from your
phone is beneficial.
Being alone with your
thoughts is beneficial.
But making crazy health promises,
too far.
- [Ryan] You guys know
I can't swim really.
Well, I can't float either.
I am negative buoyant somehow.
So these pools have tons of salt,
like 2,500 pounds of salt,
- Very salty.
- [Ryan] and salt makes you float.
- It does make you float.
It also makes it a problem if
the water gets into your eyes.
They usually give you like a
little floating pillow as well.
And I remember the one that I went to
had an emergency escape
button to call for help.
- [Ryan] Around two hours
and four minutes-ish
is where something
actually crazy happened.
I really feel like my mind was
the only thing working at this point.
I suddenly felt like I
infiltrated this memory
that I haven't thought of in years
because I felt so still.
- Well, for me, I had a similar experience
that I would start seeing different colors
and brainstorming much
further than I usually do.
- [Ryan] This was my body
while running 80 miles per week
and eating 3,000 calories a day.
- Yo, my man is ripped!
And he's running 80 miles a week?
Woo wee!
- [Ryan] This was my body
while only lifting weights
and eating 4,000 calories a day.
- Well, yeah, if you eat a lot
of calories and only lift weights,
that could be a problem.
I mean, it depends what kind
of calories you're consuming.
Remember, macronutrients matter here.
- [Ryan] I wanted to
know what would happen
if I only do bodyweight
workouts in virtual reality.
Dat VR.
For 30 days while on a strict diet
of 2,000 daily calories
and a goal of having fun.
- Well, that's an important goal.
'Cause when you're trying
to change your body,
if you're not having fun,
it's gonna be temporary.
You wanna develop good habits here.
- It's day one and it's time for weigh in.
All right, here we go.
See, 157.7.
- Ideally, you wanna
do that in the morning
with no clothes on to get
the most accurate measurement
after you've peed and pooped.
- Oh my God, dude.
- Oh, this is.
Is this Beat Saber?
(Ryan laughing)
Oh, this is giving me a headache.
- What heck is this?
- By the way, I've played these VR games.
I get so dizzy.
- This is actually so scary.
What's up, bud?
Get popped.
- Oh my God.
Oh my God.
(dramatic music)
Are we gonna have Ryan
Trahan on Creator Clash 2?
Day 12 he's eating a burger.
- Out of everything, the
diet is the hardest part.
- Diet is the hardest part,
and it's the most important part
when changing how you look.
- Oh my gosh.
150 flat.
So here's the before and after.
Honestly, I would give most of the credit
to my transformation, to the diet.
- Of course, you cut down
from eating 4,000 to 2,000.
That makes sense.
- This is a penny.
- One Penny Challenge time.
- And I'm gonna use it across
America in the next 30 days.
- And he's coming to see Jimmy.
- Rule number one, all profit
must come from the penny.
- All power must come from the penny.
- Big overarching goal for this series is
to raise 1 million meals
with Feeding America.
(bell dings)
- He does it.
We did it. (laughs)
- I look like Mr. Krabs.
- My man got sunburned already.
Put some sunblock on, dude.
Even if a few sunburns
throughout your lifetime
increases the risk for skin cancer.
You're out in the sun,
put on sunblock, Ryan.
I'm only yelling because
I care about your health,
and I don't want you to get skin cancer.
By the way, sunblock is not
the number one protection
against the sun.
It's shade.
- But if you wanna donate the incentives,
this, this, this, this.
- Yeah!
100,000.
- McDonald's.
I'm gonna treat myself to a
deluxe breakfast this morning.
- Well see, this is like
the unfortunate reality
of the United States.
Like if you wanna save money, eat cheap.
You often times have to eat unhealthy.
- Chipotle.
- Oh, I love Chipotle!
- Oh my God.
I love Chipotle.
Chipotle is my life.
(static buzzes)
- By the way, something I never say,
and I probably should,
Chipotle always hooks up
my graduating residents
for their party, with
a catered Chipotle meal
for free 'cause that's awesome of them.
- I'm gonna take a
break and eat a burrito.
- My order is usually a Burrito Bowl.
Brown rice, black beans,
chicken, fajita vegetables,
romaine lettuce, the
non-spicy tomato thingy.
What is it called?
Salsa?
Oh, and guac.
- A McDouble maybe?
- [Cashier] I think the McDouble
probably would be cheapest.
- Okay. Cool.
Can I just get that with
cheese and ketchup only?
- This is not a healthy way to eat.
Please find healthier ways to eat, Ryan.
I care about your health.
We need the veggies.
- Can I get two McChickens
with no vegetables?
- No vegetables!?
You're gonna pay for that.
- With white rice, chicken,
and shredded cheese.
White rice, chicken, and cheese.
- Dude, fiber.
There's veggies right there.
They're fresh.
They don't even cost extra.
We're gonna get Ryan to eat some veggies.
You know.
- So last night before
bed, I went to Ralphs.
I went to a grocery store,
and we got Goldfish, Rainbow
Goldfish, protein bars.
- What kind of protein bars are those?
Fudge graham?
A lot of sugar alcohols in those bad boys.
Or some kind of artificial
sweeteners leading
to terrible diarrhea.
What a sugar alcohol is,
just so people understand.
It tastes like sugar, similar
to sugar in that it's sweet,
but then your body can't absorb it.
So if you don't absorb
it, those large molecules
hang out in your intestines,
and then through osmotic
pressure, suck in water.
(bomb explodes)
And then as a result, you
have lots of diarrhea.
(upbeat music)
Did he just order tuna and rice?
- [Ryan] Oh yeah.
- How is that the solution to his issue?
- [Ryan] Ayo, tuna and rice check.
- Can you at least get a fruit, bro?
Just for God's sakes, eat a berry.
(static buzzes)
(dramatic organ music)
The One Penny Man
himself, what's up, buddy?
- Doctor Mike, you're amazing, dude.
- No, dude, you're amazing.
- You're incredible.
- And you're looking a little
bit disheveled, I gotta say.
What's going on, buddy?
- I'm delivering burritos on the highway.
- I hope you're being careful
'cause, you know, as a doctor I have
to preach safety here for you.
- I found a bike lane.
We're good.
- How is the journey so far?
- It's been the craziest thing
I've ever done in my life.
It's day 19 right now,
but it's been so fun, so rewarding.
I can't believe the
generosity that I've seen.
It's been so inspiring.
My heart is so full right now.
- Dude, you had a goal of 100,000,
and now you've already crushed that goal.
What's the new goal?
You have to have a new goal in mind.
- New goal is $1 million.
- I think you're pretty close.
I think you're very close
to that, aren't you?
- We're getting there.
We're getting there.
It's very realistic
which is insane at this point
- I will say, watching your vlog,
I was a little bit upset
and nervous for you at the same time.
A, what's going on with the veggies, man?
You don't like veggies?
(Ryan laughs)
- I don't like vegetables.
I have to take supplements for vitamins,
because I don't eat many vegetables.
- The natural form is better, man.
Well, okay.
I won't harp too hard
on the veggies thing,
and you'll see why in a minute or so.
But the next thing is,
I gotta get you to wear sunblock
'cause in that first
video, you got burned.
I hope you're wearing sunblock now.
- I got some.
I got some, Doctor Mike.
- But you must be getting
into ridiculous shape.
You're biking every
day for how many hours?
- I have an Oura Ring,
and it's tracking my daily calorie input,
and I'm hitting like 4,500
calories burned a day
which is insane.
20 miles of walking, 25
miles of biking a day.
It's gnarly.
- I know that the perk
of donating over $100,000
was that you will be
willing to get a tattoo done
by that person's choice of tattoo.
- That's right.
- And to make it interesting,
I've come up with four options for you.
- Ooh. Okay.
- Those options are not really for you.
Those four options are
for the fans to choose,
and I'm gonna put up a
poll of the four options.
But I will give you an
opportunity right now
to sway the vote in any
way that you want it to go.
- Okay. Okay.
- Are you ready to hear the four options?
- I'm so ready, Doctor Mike.
- Option number one, this
is the most heartfelt one.
You will get tattooed on your body,
a QR code
that anyone can scan
and donate to the charity
of your choice at any time.
- That's amazing.
I actually like that.
That's not bad at all.
- Number two, this one is personal to me,
and it's some piece of
advice that is not only good
for you, especially, but also
for the rest of the world.
"Eat Your Veggies".
So you're gonna get a tattoo
that says "Eat Your Veggies".
- That's amazing.
Okay. Okay.
- To help remind you
and remind the world how
important it is to eat vegetables.
- Yeah, I think so.
I need to see that on
my body every morning.
- This one is in memory
of the Penny Challenge
with the goal of your
Penny Challenge all-in-one,
option three.
What do you think about that?
- Oh my gosh.
Please,
no.
(both laughing)
I really hope it's not that one.
- We've redesigned the penny to say
"In Subs We Trust" with
good old Jimmy on the penny.
- Oh gosh.
That's so funny.
Getting Mr. Beast on my body forever.
- How would you feel about that?
How would you feel if
you had to rock that?
- Less excited than the others.
- And the next one is
one that is kind of evil.
You're not gonna like this one.
- Oh no.
- But if your fans are very angry,
they might give you this one.
- Okay.
- We kind of gave you a basic tattoo idea.
One that incorporates
everything that you've seen
in every basic tattoo ever,
and this was actually hand drawn
by Kallmekris of TikTok
fame and YouTube fame.
- Amazing.
- "Live, Laugh, Love" to infinity
with the dolphin and the butterfly wings.
- That is so funny.
Oh my gosh, that's hilarious.
(Doctor Mike laughing)
That might be one of the best ones.
- Wait, no way, you like this one?
I thought you would hate this.
- I'm goofy with it.
I think that's hilarious.
- Which one do you want
people to vote for?
- I desperately want for everyone,
because of my health in the future,
"Eat Your Veggies".
That'd be a great one for me.
I would get the reminder daily,
and I might actually start eating them.
- You heard it here from Ryan
himself, the One Penny Man.
But we'll see what the audience decides.
- Amazing, Doctor Mike.
Let me know.
I love you so much.
Thank you for the generosity.
This is so exciting.
- Of course, man.
Good luck.
Most importantly, please
stay safe out there.
- Yes.
- We want you in one piece,
especially with all the
good that you're doing.
Thank you, man.
Be well.
- Awesome. Thanks, Doctor Mike.
Take care.
- Talk soon.
Remember, you get to
choose Ryan Trahan's tattoo
that will live on his body
for the rest of his life.
The four options are right here.
The link is down below to vote.
It's basically my Twitter,
so you can just head
onto my Twitter and vote.
Choose.
If you want to go with what he wants,
you wanna go with what I want,
go with what you want.
The world is your oyster.
Check out also this video where I reacted
to some of the most
unhealthy, maybe even healthy,
Mr. Beast stunts.
Click here, check that out.
And as always, stay happy and healthy.
(easy-going music)